[Música]
se trata del río más largo de francia y
también el último aún salvaje
su naturaleza bruta y sus paisajes de
postal inspiraron a los más grandes
pintores
pero actualmente la polución los cambios
climáticos y la afluencia turística
amenaza en peligrosamente su biotopo
y por andré animador en la casa del hoy
organiza entonces regularmente salidas
para sensibilizar al público
esta tarde durante una hora les haremos
descubrir en la vida y la naturaleza que
hay en las orillas
nos interesamos en los árboles
esto es un fresno esto es un pequeño
pedazo de la hoja del fresno voy a
explicarles la hoja del fresno decimos
que está compuesta mira
esta es una hoja de fresno to call cast
es sólo una parte de la hoja pero bueno
es suficiente se llama folio love
julio.lo
podrán decirme lo que hacen
estos alumnos de iu se descubren a sí la
flora y la fauna y la arena de las
orillas del loira
un aprendizaje en el terreno concreto
lúdico que funciona bien con los jóvenes
aprendí a reconocer las piedras
también las hojas de los árboles
y qué fue lo que más te gustó
se aplican a observar los patos me gustó
ya
aprendí que los castores comían cortezas
mismo lugar otro público esta tarde eric
conduce a los miembros de su asociación
a observar castores
y
aquí hay un túnel que va la isla esta es
una zona por donde puede pasar
tras dos horas de observación un solo
castor mostró el extremo de su bigote
para los participantes así todos no
hayan logrado ver al roedor lo esencial
es pasar una tarde en la orilla de loira
humanamente desde todos estos años nos
damos cuenta de que necesitamos estar
conectados con la naturaleza sobre todo
cuando estamos en la ciudad y esto es
una zambullida en la naturaleza
tenemos la suerte de contar muy cerca de
casa viviendo en el centro con el loira
que está al lado con posibilidades de
descubrimiento al alcance de todos
animales pero también aves flores
finalmente hay muchas cosas árboles
veces muchas especies de peces
lo que constituye la riqueza del río
también es su vida acuática
[Música]
durante el ciclo pasado el salmón era la
fortuna de los pescadores del loira
poblado al río en grandes cantidades
pero actualmente están en vía de
extinción a favor de un pez más grande
el siluro
proveniente de europa del este- fue
introducido a francia durante los años
desde entonces prolifera en todos los
ríos
de 1 a 2 metros por 100 kilos
dimensiones impresionantes un bello
trofeo para los pescadores
este es uno pequeño pero también un
peligro para el ecosistema
el siluro se volvió la especie principal
del loira y como es un súper depredador
limita fuertemente la abundancia de
otras especies digamos que es un factor
adicional que se agrega a los otros
riesgos de ciertas especies tal como los
peces migratorios
pero no solo los depredadores amenazan
los peces del loira la proliferación de
las algas verdes degrada fuertemente la
calidad del agua
lo que entristece es ver que el agua
aparece limpias porque el agua es clara
es bastante translúcidas
pero cuando uno mira bien hay cantidades
considerables de pedazos de algas verdes
filamentosas que bajan rápidamente que
derivan al ahora es porque tenemos una
especie de moluscos invasiva proveniente
del mekong un río del sudeste asiático
que es un río tropical que invadió en la
vida
este molusco asiático se come el
fitoplancton que normalmente filtra los
nitratos provenientes de la agricultura
intensiva
una catástrofe que provoca una marea
verde interna
a más largo plazo otro fenómeno amenaza
el loira
cada verano el caudal del agua disminuye
cada vez más
los servicios del estado usan barreras
para mantener un nivel mínimo de agua en
el lecho del río
pero qué pasará en un futuro si el
calentamiento global continúa los
científicos consideran que en el 2050 el
caudal del loira podría ser dividido por
[Música]